tous ces
[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue au parlement européen
à bruxelles pour un nouveau numéro d'
europe hebdo à cette semaine focus sur
thierry breton si emmanuel macron
propose thierry breton à la commission
européenne c'est peut-être parce que
l'homme en question et multi facettes
élus en poitou pdg de france télécom
ministre de l'économie sous jacques
chirac est de nouveau pdg d'atos un
géant du numérique
ac v fournit un pour un poste au
périmètre très large
le futur commissaire français s'occupera
entre autres d'industrie de marché
intérieur et de défense et déjà les
critiques 1 se font entendre les députés
européens d'opposition ils voient un
risque de conflit d'intérêts il lui
reste à passer le cap des prochaines
auditions parlement européen ce sera à
la mi novembre
on en débat avec nos invités en deuxième
partie d'émission le sujet d'actualité
cette semaine c'est la campagne
électorale qui bat son plein au royaume
uni les partis politiques britanniques
ont lancé leur campagne électorale en
vue des législatives anticipées du 12
décembre chacun peaufine sa position
pour le break site on regarde et on
réagit juste après
[Musique]
et revoilà la grande bretagne en
campagne électorale ce qui mobilise les
britanniques ces jours ci ce sont les
prochaines élections législatives
anticipées fixées au 12 décembre
la campagne a débuté la semaine dernière
des grands partis se sont mis en ordre
de bataille pour tenter de convaincre
des électeurs un peu déboussolée et le
break site ne sera pas forcément
l'unique thème de cette élection
[Applaudissements]
le gouvernement conservateur réduit les
impôts des plus riches et les services
essentiels
mais le vrai changement est à venir
cette élection est une chance unique de
transformer notre pays
johnson qui avait promis que le rexy
aurait lieu le 31 octobre a tenté de se
dédouaner
lors d'une visite à l'hôpital je suis
incroyablement frustré que nous ne
soyons pas en mesure de mettre en place
leur existe aujourd'hui
mais ne doutez pas de ce qui s'est passé
nous avions un accord fantastique sur la
table la chambre des communes a adopté
mais elle ensuite voter à nouveau en
faveur d'un délai supplémentaire
les libéraux-démocrates honteux choisi
de faire campagne en promettant
d'arrêter le break site
les premiers sondages donnent le parti
conservateur largement en tête des
intentions de vote
[Musique]
nous a rejoints sur ce plateau gabriel
grésillons bonjour aussi d'avoir accepté
notre invitation vous êtes journaliste
correspondant à bruxelles pour le
journal les échos ces législatives
anticipées c'est un pari risqué pour
boris johnson écoutez si on regarde les
sondages on se dit qu'il va de l'avant
ce que ça devrait pouvoir fonctionner
simplement on a acquis un peu
d'expérience au cours des dernières
années avec le royaume uni et on se
souvient très bien du scénario des
dernières législatives qui avaient été
décidées par teresa may ou sur le papier
elle avait de l'avancé puis 7-7 avance
elle s'est réduite dans la dernière
ligne droite il y à une volatilité des
lectorats britannique qui est évidente
il ya des conditions on dit beaucoup que
le fait que ça ait lieu en hiver peut
perturber le scrutin
donc oui je pense que sur le papier il a
de la vente mais dans la réalité c'est
un pari risqué parce que tout ce qui a
trait au brésil est risqué au
royaume-uni notamment sur le brick city
un accord de sortie du royaume uni de
l'union européenne mais bruxelles a
donné un nouveau délai à 31 janvier 2020
pour faire valider cet accord quel
agenda maintenant pour le break site que
quel est l'état d'esprit à bruxelles
alors pour ce qui concerne l'agenda j'ai
envie de vous dire que le bric site ce
qui le caractérise désormais c'est qu'il
ya plus d'agenda en fait c'est à dire
que on a pris l'habitude de fixer des
échéances et que ces échéances soient
pulvérisés
donc qu'est ce qui va se passer là on a
tous la date effectivement du 31 janvier
en tête le scénario idéal c'est qu'il y
ait au terme de l'élection législative
une majorité claire qui permettent de
valider l'accord de le ratifier des deux
côtés et d'avoir une sortie ordonnée du
royaume uni au 31 janvier
mais en vérité personne ne sait si c'est
ça qui va se passer et on a forcément un
petit pressentiment que l'histoire
pourrait se répéter
quant à l'état d'esprit il a quand même
un peu évolué c'est à dire que je dirais
qu'il ya un an on était encore en mode
un peu panique est ici à bruxelles
maintenant c'est plutôt une forme de
lassitude voire de résignation et il ya
chez certains une envie
d'abord et avant tout d'en finir alors
que je vous dis il ya un an on se disait
cet horrible au royaume uni va sortir
peut-être sans accord et c'est
maintenant l'histoire prouve que sans
accord bas en fait on n'y va pas
vraiment au brésil sans accord enfin on
fait tout pour l'éviter
donc voilà il ya plutôt une forme de
fatigue et une envie d'enfiler une envie
d'en finir justement chez les vingt-sept
jusqu'où est-on prêt à faire état de de
bienveillance vis-à-vis de londres alors
c'est sur ce point que je dirais que on
a beaucoup dit pendant toute la
négociation du bric site que l'unité des
vingt-sept étaient impressionnantes et
c'est vrai sur cette question de la
bienveillance à l'égard des du royaume
uni a peut-être une ligne de faille qui
est apparue laquelle il y à des pays
j'ai envie de dire dont le chef de file
et l'allemagne qui considère que le
départ du royaume uni est une tragédie
pour toutes sortes de raisons pour des
raisons commerciales évidemment
peut-être aussi pour des raisons d'
équilibre des pouvoirs au sein de lieux
parce qu'il ya des pays qui pensent que
s'il ya plus l'angleterre pour faire
contrepoids à la france est bien la
france va peut-être être tentés de 2-1
peu l'attelage elle toute seule
donc il ya toutes sortes de raisons qui
font que certains pays sont prêts un peu
à tout pour garder le royaume uni dans
l'union européenne lui offrir des délais
lui donner x opportunité de changer
d'avis et puis on a d'autres emmené par
la france qui ne se réjouissent pas du
tout du royaume-uni du pardon du
breakbeat
mais qui pense que il est urgent de
sortir de cette impasse et qui donc
voit le prix de l'incertitude mais
maintenant là où il faut pas être trop
binaire c'est à dire que même en
allemagne les états d'esprit évolué on
se rend compte que dans les milieux
d'affaires il ya beaucoup de gens qui
disent le coup de l'incertitude devient
trop énorme
finissons-en donc corps politique
fiction a si les anti break 6 de cette
fois gagnent les élections législatives
on fait quoi
c'est retour à la case départ nouveau
référendum c'est possible moi je ne peux
absolument pas me prononcer sur quelle
quelle tournure va prendre la vie
politique au royaume-uni est ce qu'ils
vont décider d'un nouveau référendum
peut-être je n'en sais rien il ya
beaucoup de si dans cette question ce
qui est certain c'est qu'ici il émerge
un jour une ou un consensus en tout cas
une majorité au royaume uni pour en
finir avec le brésil au sens pour
renoncer au brésil
ils ont un claquement de doigts à faire
et c'est fini c'est à dire que au plan
juridique le fameux article 50 qu'ils
ont enclenchée pour sortir de l'union
européenne le jour où il décide qu'il
retire l'article 50
ils sont membres de plein droit comme si
rien n'avait eu lieu donc le scénario
d'un da d'un revirement de l'histoire
d'une annulation du brésil
il n'est pas du tout à exclure encore
faut-il qu émerge une majorité sur ce
sujet donc on l'aura compris tout est
possible tout est possible rien n'est
certain
merci galerie grésillons pour cet
éclairage la voilà donc élections
législatives en grande bretagne le jeudi
12 décembre et on aura les résultats le
vendredi 13 décembre à vie au
superstitieux voilà notre grand débat du
jour concerne un ancien ministre thierry
breton il est annoncé comme nouveau
candidat français à la commission
européenne il ya quelques semaines
les eurodéputés avaient projeté la
candidature de sylvie goulard
mais même pour l'ancien ministre de
l'économie de jacques chirac à certains
parlent déjà de conflit d'intérêts mais
qui est thierry breton vous allez le
voir il est multi facettes de l'homme de
réseau à l'écrivain en passant par le
geek on regarde son portrait et on débat
juste après
thierry breton proposé par emmanuel
macron à la commission européenne
peut-être parce que l'homme en question
est multicarte un parcours de redresseur
d'entreprises d'abord par dont une passe
thierry breton impose des plans
d'économies tout en lançant des
acquisitions stratégiques qu'il a passé
un peu plus de deux ans à france télécom
est le bilan de sa politique c'est près
de 20 mille suppressions d'emploi en
deux temps mais la méthode fait ses
preuves avec lui france télécom thompson
ou bull se redresse multicartes thierry
breton est aussi un passionné de
nouvelles technologies dans les années
80 le jeune ingénieur créer son
entreprise informatique
à l'époque il appuie guet apens c est
maintenant la branche et d'un
informaticien c'est à dire que
circulaire si je peux dire multicartes
avec la politique qui s'invite dans son
parcours en 1986 il entre au cabinet de
rené monory qui lui confie la création
du futuroscope de poitiers le
futuroscope bon j'ai l'impression que
c'est un peu la rencontre du rêve
elle a beaucoup et de la technologie
également nous avons effectivement
essayé de construire quelque chose pour
ces enfants qui passeront leur bac
après l'an 2000 hommes d'amitié et
surtout on de réseau thierry breton se
lie à jacques chirac en 2005 le grand
patron est nommé ministre de l'économie
un mélange des genres qui dérange déjà à
l'époque c'est à ce mélange là qu'il
faut mettre fin il ya d'un côté la
gestion des fonds
dans le cadre de laquelle les français
veulent de la simplicité de la
transparence et de la moralité et
d'autre part la gestion d'une entreprise
à bercy l'ancien patron a une obsession
la tête d'oubli sa franche d'aujourd'hui
vit au dessus de ses moyens mais la
victoire de nicolas sarkozy en 2007 les
douanes de la politique
thierry breton multicartes là encore
prend la tête d'atos un géant du
numérique
le futur commissaire français quels
qu'ils soient s'occupera entre au
d'industrie de marché intérieur ou de
défense il sera notamment en charge de
la cybersécurité de l'intelligence
artificielle ou encore des
supercalculateurs autant de thématiques
directement liées à l'activité d'atos
le bébé de fihri breton les députés
européens d'opposition y voient un
risque de conflit d'intérêts sur
l'examen des conflits d'intérêts nous on
va faire un travail de manière vous
aussi scrupuleuse que ce qu'on a fait
pour les autres commissaires on va lui
poser des questions notamment sur
l'entreprise
atos qu'il dirige et qui a reçu des
subventions européennes
on ne peut pas réguler l'industrie et en
même temps avoir des intérêts dans cette
industrie
sinon il ya un conflit nanterre après le
rejet de la candidature de sylvie
goulard
emmanuel macron prend t-il le risque
d'un nouveau camouflet pour lui c'est
n'en faut aussi savoir ce qu'on appelle
conflit d'intérêts est ce que quand il
était chez atos qui pensaient qu'il à
devenir commissaire européen n'ont ils
rien qui pouvait l'établir même jusqu'à
15 jours
est ce que quand il était ado s'il a pu
bénéficier quelque chose non la question
qui va être posée et ce sur quoi il
apportera toutes les réponses
c est ce que il a coupé tous les liens
avec l'entreprise sur le plan personnel
et sur quels dossiers devraient se
déporter une entreprise comme atos sur
le portefeuille qui est sans doute l'un
des plus grands de la commission qui
couvre le marché intérieur le numérique
et la défense se sera pas un problème de
fonctionnement bien sûr et thierry
breton a été un soutien d' emmanuel
macron dès le premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle il lui reste à passer le
cap des prochaines auditions
mi-novembre au parlement européen
voilà pour le portrait précisons que le
candidat français la commission
européenne thierry breton actuel pdg du
groupe de services informatiques atos a
ne possédera plus aucune action si sa
nomination est confirmée par le
parlement européen cela signifie que les
titres qu'ils possèdent seront cédés
précise-t-on du côté de son entourage et
ce afin d'éviter tout conflit tout
risque de conflit la terre nous ont
joints sur ce plateau stéphane séjourné
bonjour bonjour vous êtes eurodéputés
élus en mai dernier sur la liste de la
majorité présidentielle à vous faites
partie du groupe renault en europe
renouveler l'europe a le groupe du
parlement européen où siègent les
députés français de renaissance à la
liste soutenue par la république en
marche merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation philippe lambert
bonjour je tête eurodéputés de belgique
à du groupe des verts ici au parlement
européen vous n'êtes pas un novice
ici au parlement européen élu pour la
première fois en 2009 à c'est donc votre
troisième mandat merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation faille manuel foulon
bonjour bonjour
cela fait dix ans que vous êtes un
expert en stratégie politique et
affaires européennes à vous nous avez
travaillé pour plusieurs eurodéputés et
délégation socialiste question est ce
que est ce que thierry breton est un bon
candidat stéphane ces journées ouais je
pense que ça revienne conduire la wii
confiant et à la fois je pense qu'il
coché toutes les cases du portefeuille
sur lesquels il doit mener à bien son
exercice à la commission on avait des
interrogations sur laquelle l'ampleur en
tout cas du portefeuille chanceux tirés
breton à la fois avec ses compétences
sur le numérique sur le marché intérieur
et sur le volet défense votre reportage
le montre pas mais il a aussi été à
l'initiative du fonds européen de
défense
en tout cas il y à travailler donc sur
tous ces sujets là évidemment on est
plutôt confiant et puis ça sera mon avis
un bon élément pour la commission il est
au service de l'intérêt général européen
et c'est ce portefeuille n'appartient
pas à la france mais aussi à la
commission et c'est ça qu'il faut aussi
obtenir de sa domination une plante
verte vous voterez pour contre alors je
supporte commission des affaires
juridiques la nomination de thierry
breton a les compétences pour le poste
je pense que la réponse est oui ça je
pense que ça ne se discute pas est-ce
que
il a voté pour si sous réserve de ce que
la commission des affaires juridiques et
son audition donnera je l' ai rencontré
lundi dernier et il m'a fait plutôt
bonne impression
c'est un européen convaincu là dessus
pas de discussions non plus et donc la
question centrale est celle des conflits
d'intérêts et là dessus vous avez
rencontrées vous l'avait titillé ou la
sépaq rythme et je lui ça a été la
première question on n'y a pas ces 25
minutes et il a répondu de manière
extrêmement circonstanciés à la question
des conflits d'intérêts doc à la fois
les conflits d'intérêts financiers liés
à son patrimoine propre et là j'ai cru
comprendre que des décisions drastiques
avaient déjà été prises par lui sans
même savoir s'il serait s'il serait
confirmée par le parlement européen ou
non il ya la question évidemment des
relations avec son ancienne boîte
puisque jusque vendredi dernier il
dirigeait atos et atos est un
fournisseur de l'union européenne donc
il faut bien faut bien préciser il ya la
question de atos comme fournisseur et
puis à la question de atos comme
bénéficiaire de subsides européens en
particulier dans le domaine de la
recherche
et là il a il appartiendra à thierry
breton de se tenir à distance de toute
décision qui pourrait impliquer son
ancien groupe quand bien même ils
détiendraient plus d'action c'est clair
qu'on ne peut pas avoir dirigé un groupe
jusqu'à il ya une semaine
et puis être insensible à ce groupe dans
les mois et les années qui viennent
et donc il faudra que l'on puisse pas
suspecter thierry breton dans l'exercice
de son mandat moyennant des engagements
très clairs là dessus alors je pense que
thierry breton pourrait être confirmé il
ya un point que je voudrais souligner
ces latitudes autant emmanuel macron et
sylvie goulard incarne est incarné une
forme d'arrogance française autant
thierry breton est plutôt sympa enfin je
dis c'est quelqu'un qui ne la ramène pas
lourdement quoi et ça je pense que c'est
quelque chose qui risque de toucher
sympathiquement les députés manuel
foulon et quand on est compétent dans un
domaine faudrait surtout pas qu'on s'en
occupe au niveau européen c'est ce que
c'est pas ça le procès qu'on fait à
thierry breton est ce qui ferait un bon
commissaire européen est une bonne
question en fait si j'étais son coach
pour passer les auditions je lui
donnerai trois conseils 1 comme l'a dit
philippe lambert effectivement être
beaucoup moins arrogant qu'il a été
servi goulard parce que ça lui a coûté
cher
2 je lui proposerais évidemment de
vendre toutes les actions quelles
qu'elles soient pour paraître les mains
propres et pour éviter les conflits
d'intérêts et puis 3 je jouerai mon
expérience effectivement il a été chef
d'entreprise ici qu'on a à l'industrie
s'y connaît en finance il s'y connaît en
super calculateur en numérique en
innovation donc il a il a le bon job
description il a la bonne expérience ça
va de soi et puis ça évitera aussi
d'avoir six mois si mac ou quelquefois
les anciens commissaires met du temps à
rentrer dans les matières là on va
gagner six mois de temps et du coup
d'efficacité maintenant une fois qu'on a
parlé ça la question éthique arrive de
savoir est ce qu'il sera capable de
couper ses liens financiers bien sûr
mais aussi d'amitié avec les entreprises
pour lesquelles il a travaillé avec les
autres capitaines d'entreprise avec les
lobbys est-ce qu'il sera capable sans
conséquence de travailler pour trente
fois son salaire dès 2017 parce qu'en
2017 il a touché jusqu'à 6 millions
d'euros quand même et enfin est ce qu'il
sera atteint du symptôme que
j'appellerais le syndrome d'une videur
de discothèque c'est à dire que quand
vous êtes videurs d'une discothèque vous
les mois passant les années passant vous
faites 30 contes vous fait rentrer plus
facilement certaines personnes parce que
vous les connaissez
quelquefois même sens les fouilles à
l'entrée ça évidemment mais comme ces
européens on ne peut pas accepter ne
peut pas accepter qu'un commissaire
européen se fasse ordonné les nouvelles
législations par les lobbys ça c'est
important et donc la question sera de
savoir s'il peut d'un point de vue
éthique occupé les fonctions si la
réponse est oui il fera un très bon
commissaire stéphane séjourné à thierry
breton pdg d'atos l'un des leaders
mondial du numérique et reçoit des
subventions l'adie européenne notamment
pour fabriquer ces super calculateur ses
ordinateurs hyper puissant où il est
numéro un dans le marché va falloir
qu'ils se déporte thierry breton quand
il va une fois la commission quand il
travaillera sur sur le numérique
je crois qu'il l'a lui-même dit un des
ports sur un certain nombre de sujets
qui sont liées aux entreprises qu'il a
dirigé et puis également des sujets qui
ont été déjà annoncées en tout cas pas
retiré breton lui-même ventes
automatiques de ses actions et donc il
sera totalement libre moi je voulais
retenir deux points notamment sur les
conflits d'intérêts d'abord sur le
process actuelle aujourd'hui au
parlement européen qui pas un process
satisfaisant et je pense que d'ailleurs
tous est d'accord là dessus on demande
aux parlementaires européens en réalité
rés la partie administrative en quelque
sorte du l'évaluation du conflit
d'intérêts on ne demande pas aux
parlementaires européens de légiférer
sur le degré de transparence comme dans
tous les parlements nationaux ça se fait
et confié sa éventuellement est une
autorité administrative indépendante
elle même regarde les sanctions
éventuelles et évaluent si la grille de
lecture qu'on fixe et les parlements et
bien confirmée donc je voulais le strict
au niveau des commissaires européens au
niveau des députés européens
et puis je pense 1 c'est sûr et puis 2
je pense qu'il faut faire rentrer des
hauts fonctionnaires également de la
commission dans cette grille puisque le
conflit d'intérêts ne concerne pas
uniquement ni les parlementaires ni les
commissaires mais également faire et
donc ça c'est le premier point c'est le
premier point un deuxième point la
question du conflit d'intérêts ça
analyse surtout dans le sens public
privé et d'ailleurs on n'est pas assez
attentif à ces sujets là quand on est
dans une fonction publique
aujourd'hui vous pouvez être penser à
votre job d'après éventuellement même le
créer éventuellement donner des
satisfactions une entreprise qui
pourrait vous embaucher et puis vous
pouvez partir avec des informations que
vous ne devez pas avoir dans le privé en
termes de concurrence par rapport aux
autres boitement tous et tous ces sujets
là sont pas réellement posé et c'est au
moment où il ya une transition
aujourd'hui entre une équipe sortante
est une équipe en 30
on se fixe évidemment politiquement sur
l'équipe entrante et on regarde beaucoup
moins l'équipe sortante
on devrait d'ailleurs s'intéressait
beaucoup plus haut par le
haut-commissaire et aux administrateurs
et aux directeurs d'administrations qui
sortent et qui vont dans le privé moi je
pense que c'est ces deux sujets à la
fois la procédure parlementaire en tant
que telle est à la fois la question du
public privé qu'il faut que hors
position au parlement européen je pense
que c'est c'est d'intérêt général des
choses qu au port depuis très longtemps
ici mais de nouveau il est quand même
frappant que on a énormément de mal ici
au sein du parlement européen a trouvé
les majorité de députés prêts à mettre
en place une autorité indépendante comme
vous le suggérez sur le modèle français
je pense que là dessus la haute autorité
français c'est un bon ans par ans de
l'année d'elle mais il
pas de majorité politique ici pour le
faire et en effet c'est pas seulement
les commissaires s'est plaint de députés
qui ont en même temps qu'ils sont
députés des déposes d'administrateurs de
sociétés et personnes enfin personne ne
trouve rien à redire si nous on trouve
des choses à redire à ça mais c'est pas
normal on est payé plein temps par le
contribuable européen il est normal que
le contribuable européen puisse attendre
de nous un plein temps en politique et
donc on ne fait rien ailleurs on vient à
un autre sujet donc qui le commissaire
européen futur commissaire robé à
thierry breton il a été proposé par la
france en tant que commissaire pour un
très vaste portefeuille à comprenant la
politique industrielle le marché
intérieur le numérique la défense et
l'espace
est ce qu'il n'est pas trop vaste ce
portefeuille est ce qui peut garder le
numérique
manuel foulon oui il est beaucoup trop
vaste en fait déjà la répartition des
portefeuilles a été mal faite
le portefeuille ici gilles en a pas on
dirait ce qui m'intéresse c'est le
portefeuille oui évidemment parce que
bien sûr il s'agit c'est la commission
européenne qui décide du champ d'action
autour de chaque commissaire mais il est
clair aussi que c'était manuel macron
qui a négocié en amont la taille du
portefeuille et je comprend volontiers
parce que du coup ça donne une influence
énorme sur les secteurs d'activité qui
sont dans le portefeuille donc ça je
l'entends après là où j'ai aussi un
problème c'est que finalement vous
trouve toujours pas donc vous vous
retrouvez avec des commissaires de 1re
2e division pour trouver des
commissaires et les sous-commissaire
dieu sait que je me bats pour l'égalité
des gens pour le droit des femmes tout
ça vraiment c'est important et on est
encore bien loin d'y arriver mais
regardez vous avez un commissaire qui
s'occupe de l'égalité des genres et vous
avez un commissaire qui s'occupe du
marché intérieur de l'industrie de la
défense le numérique est réduit de
l'espace il ya un déséquilibre total
alors de deux choses l'une soit vous
estimez et vous accepter qu'il y ait des
commissaires et laisse aux commissaires
et c'est pas terrible
évidemment pour l'image non plus les
pays qui ont un sous commissaire soit
vous dites
le portefeuille de monsieur breton c'est
d'un portefeuille à taille normale mais
alors vous ne faites plus 26 vous n'avez
plus 27 commissaires vous avez dix
commissaires et on le gagnera en argent
et peut-être en efficacité
personnellement je serais pas opposé à
un système où on a comme dans des
gouvernements nationaux des ministres et
des secrétaires d'état
autrement dit des ministres ont un grand
domaine d'activité ceci étant ici on est
aussi dans une perversion du système
parce que non seulement il est un des
sites libre énorme comme vous le disiez
entre les portefeuilles mais emmanuel
macron ne s'en cache même pas vous dites
on n'est pas propriétaire du
portefeuille je suis désolé emmanuel
macron se comporte comme si la france
était propriétaire du portefeuille et ça
ça ne va pas je rappelle que dans les
textes des traités
la location des portefeuilles est la
prérogative exclusive du ou de la
présidente de la commission est ici
c'est là qu'on mesure déjà le fait qu'en
choisissant vendeurs live on a choisi
une président de la commission faible
qui est donc soumise aux pressions de
ses commanditaires et qui sont ses
commanditaires emmanuel macron et
accessoirement un gala merkel et donc ça
c'est problématique parce que nous
voulons une commission dalhousie dans de
la soie sur l'indépendance des variables
non mais l'affluence de la france et de
l'allemagne
bien sûr sur le sur déjà sur les les
commissaires il ya dès aujourd'hui il ya
déjà une différence entre les vice
présidents de la commission
les portefeuilles et vous faisait
parallèle entre le niveau national et le
niveau européen mais dans la
constitution des gouvernements le fait
de politiquement marqué une personnalité
avec un portefeuille fort est évidemment
un champ d'application qui est un choix
politique est aujourd'hui est un choix
politique de vanderlei alors
effectivement dans fictivement donc
aujourd'hui au conseil ça c'est une
évidence mais encore une fois je vous le
dis le portefeuille ne sera pas dirigée
par un français mais par un français qui
s'occupe de l'intérêt général européen
gracieux donc moi je suis assez à l'aise
sur le fait qu' il ya des commissaires
qui ont des gros portefeuilles amène des
vice-présidents exécutifs
c'est aussi des choix politiques c'est
aussi des choix de représentation et on
est dans un régime j'ai bien au niveau
européen de la confrontation de deux
régimes entre le régime parlementaire
est presque fédéraliste dont issue on
est rangé en haut niveau du parlement
européen en appartenance politique et
ont fait fi de nos nationalités et puis
un la coopération et elle conseille ou
là on représente les états et la
commission elle est aussi à la jonction
c'est de ces deux points donc
effectivement il ya de l'influencé tati
qu il ya de l'affluence des états
membres et puis il ya aussi une prise en
compte de la part des commissaires de
l'intérêt général européen et du travail
qu'il faut qu'ils aient effectué avec
l'ensemble des groupes parlementaires
ici et je trouve que c'est assez sain
après s'il faut revoir le site
il faudra peut-être en tout cas donné le
titre de vice président à des gens qui
ont des gros portefeuilles et avoir une
forme de doctrine sur la taille et
l'importance des portefeuilles je suis
assez d'accord d'ailleurs avec monsieur
lambert dessus sur les secrétaires
d'état des ministres éventuellement
d'état des vice-présidents de la
commission il faudrait peut-être une
forme de hiérarchie qui nous ôtera qui
nous donne une doctrine qu'on puisse
expliquer il gagnera 10 fois moins à la
commission européenne que chez atos est
ce que c'est un gage d'honnêteté si les
plans dacca comment est-ce que j'irai on
peut se poser la question évidemment des
inégalités salariales en europe et c'est
sûr que ça choque quand même de voir le
type de rémunération convoi et attend ce
n'est pas encore le pire exemple on veut
dire que vous allez dans la finance vous
voyez mes rations totalement indécent
ceci étant le fait qu'il accepte de
prendre un poste comme celui là c'est
clairement pas pour l'argent
ils sont d'intérêt financier était de
rester pdg d'atos donc l'impression
qu'il m'a donné c'est que bien sûr il
n'est pas dans le besoin c'est évident
mais il ne me semble pas a priori
motivée par le toujours plus puisqu'en
l'occurrence si j'ai bien compris il a
évidemment à voir sa rémunération de
commissaires qui est en tout cas pour le
commun des mortels plantureuse mais il
renonce aussi à toucher sa pension de
retraite d'atos pendant la période où
ils seraient commises et c'est bien la
moindre des choses on va dire oui c'est
évident mais mais vous savez pour
certains tant qu'ils y ont droit
ils vont et c'est un problème de sylvie
goulard quand elle a touché trois cent
cinquante mille euros de la milliardaire
américain sa réponse était c'était légal
donc avait pas de problème
oui mais c'était est égal mais c'est
indécent et si c'est un décembre et il
faut y renoncer là dessus il me semble
que breton et plus est plus sain que
sylvie goulard ne l'était là toute la
difficulté va être de montrer qu'il n'y
a pas de conflit d'intérêt lors de cette
audition s'est tu vas y arriver ou c'est
mission impossible selon vous écoutez
honnêtement moi je pense que je pense
qu'il va y arriver on ne sera pas face à
une crise institutionnelle si jamais ça
ne se passe pas bien
contrairement ce que j'ai entendu parce
que déjà il ya plusieurs années barroso
avait été élu en février enfin avait été
votée en février d'après donc d'un point
de vue times il n'y a pas de problème
par contre d'un point de vue
d'un point de vue symbolique ce sera un
peu une catastrophe que emmanuel macron
perdre encore un candidat d'une part
parce que ce serait sûrement sa
responsabilité
c'est à dire qu'il a pris goulard alors
que tous les feux est à l'orangé au
rouge pour conflit d'intérêt est laisse
à quai il mais breton dont le seul point
faible finalement c'est un sou conflits
d'intérêts potentiels
et puis peut-être aussi que lui la le
symptôme sarkozy c'est à dire que
sarkozy quand il sortait des réunions du
conseil se précipiter en conférence de
presse pour dire la voilà la france a
gagné on a décidé ça mais en fait c'est
moi qui ai décidé pour la france ici
emmanuel macron paie peut-être aussi son
omniprésence le fait d'avoir été maître
d'oeuvre sans pitié pendant
l'attribution des top job dont un
président la commission président du
conseil présidents banques européennes
et effectivement il a très bien réussi
ces négociations pour lui pour la france
mais il n'a pas pu s'empêcher de marché
serait énormément de pied et il ya des
gens qui le prennent maintenant pour un
vrai ennemi politique ses fans ses
journées 6-2 breton est rejetée on fait
quoi
gilles absents j'y pense même pas
puisque en plus la discussion convient
d'avoir montre que normalement si tout
se passe bien et en tout cas avec les
diligences que lui même a montré avant
même une évaluation de sa déclaration
d'intérêt montre que normalement il
devrait pas y avoir de problème donc moi
je ne veux pas de rejets possibles à
dreuilhe du possible tout est possible
on est en politique est par ailleurs il
ya une évaluation tant qu'on est dans le
système que je vous décrivais avant
c'est à dire que la commission des
affaires juridiques doit analyser il
peut se passer n'importe quoi donc moi
je suis membre de cette commission
évidemment je relèverai les éléments
pragmatiques et je pense que c'est
important qu'on puisse traiter de la
même manière les commissaires européens
sont passés entre nos mains en quelque
sorte en commission des affaires
juridiques depuis depuis quelques mois
et que de thierry breton maintenant donc
si en tout cas on fait le même
traitement et qu'il n'y a pas d'
instrumentalisation politique autour de
cette question normalement tirer breton
devrait être validé en affaires
juridiques et puis après c'est à lui
aussi de contrer de faire la
démonstration aux parlementaires
européens mac il est en capacité de
gérer ce portefeuille grand comme on
vient de le dire et puis qu'il est
compétent sur ces sujets là et ça ça
sera la belle audition devant les
parlementaires
ça c'est un autre exercice est un
exercice qui à mon avis plus important
que l'exercice en commission des
affaires
monique on sera fixé bientôt à le
candidat français sera auditionné par
les députés européens sur le fond
notamment sur la politique qu'il compte
mener à son poste donc à la mi-novembre
à le 12 novembre la nouvelle commission
d'ursula von der leyen a doit prendre
ses fonctions le 1er décembre merci à
vous trois d'être venus débattre
merci à vous de nous avoir suivis bonne
suite des programmes sur les chaînes
parlementaires bail
[Musique]